It is very important that we Muslims
whenever we do
something. We have to trust in God. But
we have to tie a
camel. Tying a camel means when we do
anything we have to
plan. When we plan, we are following the
hadith of the prophet. If we don't plan,
we are not following the hadith of the
prophet. There is something called as
goal setting.
When we listen to the management gurus,
they talk about goal setting and they
have an acronym called as smart. S M A R
T. S for specific, M for
measurable,
A
for
accessible, R for realistic and T for
time
bound. This is acronym
acronym but I believe our goal setting
should be not smart. It should be
Islamic. I S L A M I C. I for Islamic.
Whatever goal you do, whatever goal you
set, it should be matching with the
teachings of Quran and Sunnah.
All our goal setting, all our actions,
all our deeds should be Islamic as per
the teachings of the Quran and the
authentic hadith. It should be as per
Islamic
Sharia. If it's against, we should not
do it. Number one, Islamic. Number two,
S S is
specific. Specific
means it should be particular. Let me
give you an example.
Once a teacher was teaching archery to
the
students and the teacher said I want you
to
aim at the bird sitting on the top of
the tree. Aim at the eye of the
bird. So all his four students they take
aim. They're doing
archery. So the teacher asked the first
student all said we have taken the aim.
What do you see? The first student say
says I see the
forest and in the forest is the tree. On
the tree is sitting a bird and I can see
the eye of the
bird. The teacher asked the second
student, "What can you see?" The second
student replies, "I see the tree. On the
tree is sitting the bird and I can see
the eye of the
bird." The teacher asked the third
student, "What do you see?" He says I
see the
bird and I see the eye of the
bird. The teacher asked the four student
what do you see? So the four students
say I see only the eye of the bird
nothing
else. The teacher says let the arrow go
and he leaves the arrow and it exactly
hits at the eye of the bird. This means
specific. Your goal should be specific
not
vague,
accurate. Third is L I is SL Islamic. L
is for lucrative. It should be
beneficial. Most of the other people
they want it to be beneficial in this
world. You know which is the best dua
that we Muslims can do.
And most of us know the
dua. Most of the Muslim know this dua.
Yes or
no? It is a verse of the Quran of Surah
Bakra chapter number two verse number
201. Oh my Lord give us the best in this
world and the Akar and save me from the
torment of hellfire. All of us know yes
or no.